and the u.s house of representatives has
backed a resolution calling for a
constitutional amendment to be used to
remove donald trump from office
the president is accused of inciting
rioters at the capitol
last week the request from the
democratic controlled house now goes to
vice president mike pence but he's
already ruled out applying
the 25th amendment to declare trump
unfit for office
maya canna reports now from washington
d.c
the resolution is adopted without
objection the motion to reconsider is
laid on the table
ultimately this appeared to be an
exercise in futility
as expected given the democrat majority
in the house the motion was passed
but this only after the vice president
stated he would not invoke the 25th
amendment
and remove president trump from office
in a letter to the speaker of the house
the vice president said
and i quote i do not believe that such a
course of action
is in the best interest of our nation or
consistent with our constitution
he added under our constitution the 25th
amendment
is not a means of punishment or
usurpation
invoking the 25th amendment in such a
manner
would set a terrible precedent
the debate did serve to indicate the
arguments that are likely to be used in
the impeachment process
that will now begin in the house on
wednesday the president
was hell-bent on trying to challenge
undermine
and overturn the results of the election
in all of the events leading up to
january 6 and on
january 6. that is a profound
dereliction
of the president's duties there are
those republicans who strongly disagreed
including one who was controversially
awarded a medal of honor by president
trump
on monday continued calls to impeach the
president
or remove him from office with using the
25th amendment i don't think are healthy
for our nation early in the day the
president made his first public
appearance since the eruption of
violence in the capital last wednesday
while visiting a portion of the border
wall
he continued to deny any responsibility
for the damage and the deaths
lashing out at those in congress seeking
his impeachment
the impeachment hoax is a continuation
of the greatest and most vicious witch
hunt
in the history of our country and is
causing tremendous anger and division
and pain
but the majority of house members are
adamant that the violence in the capital
last week
was a direct consequence of what they
call incitement
by the president the siege has resulted
in what the fbi and the acting u.s
attorney
say is the most extensive criminal
investigation
ever launched in the u.s i think the
scope and scale of this investigation in
these cases are really unprecedented not
only in
fbi history but probably doj history in
which
essentially the capital grounds outside
and inside are essentially a crime scene
charges have already been laid against
some 70 individuals
and this number will increase
substantially in the weeks
and months ahead the department of
justice says the crimes being
investigated
range from misdemeanors like trespass
to conspiracy sedition and murder
mike joins me now from washington dc uh
and mike you know the result is perhaps
a foregone conclusion we knew that was
going to happen
but the debate itself was not only
impassioned but we saw how partisan it
can be
indeed yes well it was largely partisan
but it must be immediately noted that
one republican
broke ranks and voted with the democrats
to vote was 223 to 205
one republican voting in favor of the
motion
five republicans incidentally did not
cast any vote
at all so that is perhaps a
forerunner of what may happen during the
impeachment vote which will be taking
place
in the next 24 hours already so there
are five republican representatives
who have said that they will vote to
impeach president trump
now this is a very different scenario
from the previous impeachment of
president trump
which went in the house at least
completely along
partisan lines very clearly now you have
five
republican representatives who say that
they will
vote to impeach but it was as you said a
spirited
debate about the motion to invoke the
25th
amendment largely along partisan lines
this is what some of the representatives
had to say
mr speaker this is a sad day for our
country that we have to come
to the floor in a way to defend
the constitution of the united states at
this time
the facts are very clear the president
called for this seditious attack
while section 4 of the 25th amendment
has never been used
a plain reading of the text coupled with
the context of its ratification
contemplates a very different scenario
from the one we are currently in
let's unite against donald trump who
inspired terrorists to carry a
confederate flag
into this capital display a noose and
desecrate the people's house
the vice president has given you your
answer
before you ask the question no
legitimate purpose to this resolution
remains your ultimatum does violence
to a core feature of the architecture of
the constitution
the devastating bruises on our nation's
soul
can only begin to heal by removing
the weapon used to blunt in us
the vice president must invoke the 25th
amendment
to immediately remove power
from this dangerous president this is a
deeply
unpopular impeachment the public wishes
we were here dealing with
coronavirus not the virus of trump
hatred that you seem to have found
no vaccine for well first we look
forward to
mike really you know now we're talking
about articles of impeachment to be
discussed or debated and voted on in the
house but also it's not going to be a
smooth ride for the president
in the senate senior uh republican
uh leaders there including mitch
mcconnell alluding to the fact that you
know impeachment is quite possible
well what we've seen in the house of
representatives for example
is a recommendation by the minority
leader in the house the leading
republican
that members vote with their conscience
now once again this is different from
the previous impeachment where the
instructions went out the order went out
we do not break ranks at all republicans
will oppose this impeachment
well not anymore there you've got a
direct
comment from the minority leader saying
vote with your conscience
you've got already five republicans
making very clear
that they will impeach or vote to
impeach president trump
now the result is basically given those
kind of
figures uh completely forgotten because
uh it's a simple majority in the house
as this motion was passed tonight the
motion of impeachment is going to be
passed in the course of the next 24
hours
there is one article of impeachment at
this particular point
and that is accusing president trump
of incitement to insurrection now that
is what will be debated in the course of
the day tomorrow
it is certain uh given today's figures
that the house will vote to impeach
president trump the issue that then
arises so
is whether the speak of the house holds
on
to the article of impeachment uh before
passing it on to the senate she may not
pass it on to the senate immediately she
may decide
to hold on to it for a while before it
goes to the senate for trial that is
something
that will play out but you mention as
well the senate and the same thing
occurs in the senate where
previously you had the senate majority
leader mitch mcconnell
making very clear that everybody has to
vote on block that
no dissent among republicans will be
accepted in the end one republican
senator
did break ranks but generally the
instruction from the senate majority
leader
held now there has been no such
instruction from mitch mcconnell on this
particular occasion
pending the arrival of the article of
impeachment to the senate now
another major difference as well is that
given this
um particular point there may well be
evidence allowed in the trial in the
senate when it takes place this did not
happen on the previous occasion either
so certainly things not looking very
good for president trump at all
republicans beginning to break ranks
republicans beginning to express
public support for the impeachment of
president trump
and that's likely to happen by the end
of wednesday
mike hannah in washington dc thank you